hey everyone I am so honored to let you
guys know that I am going to be
launching my live training series called
a school of life where I'm going to be
working with nine of you each week for
nine weeks to help you create your best
life I have coached hundreds of people
from around the world and I recognize
the common patterns of things that hold
people back I also have the solutions
and tools to help my clients live the
life that they really want so I've taken
everything that I know and have learned
as a coach and I put it together this 90
course just for you I made this live
training program because normally for my
coaching services I charge a hundred
dollars per hour I also recognize that
it's not affordable for a lot of people
I have seen the lives of my clients
change dramatically and I want to help
you change your life for the better
which is why I created the School of
Life to give you access to tools to help
you build the life that you really want
this is going to be an immersion program
which means that you're going to be
working intensely for nine weeks you're
going to have homework you're going to
work really hard towards building a life
that you deserve I'm keeping this small
for a reason I'm only working with nine
of you so I'm gonna give it everything
that I got to make sure that you come
out of this course change we will also
build a Facebook community just for us
because I recognize that going on a
journey of personal growth can be a
lonely one and we're much more likely to
succeed when we have people around us
who care about us and cheering us on so
you know have the opportunity through
this Facebook group to connect learn and
hold each other accountable and you also
have access to me when you need the
additional support now divided this
course into three sections section
number one is discovering your inner
self you're going to let go of who you
should be and really step into who you
truly are instead of living the life
that way your parents want or your
spouse wants what the society wants it's
time to
put an end to that and really focus on
the life that you want to build for
yourself and we're gonna do that by
number one discovering your one word
your single most important core value
you will also develop a credo which is
your personal mission statement to
living the life that you want number two
you're going to figure out how to apply
your one word and your credo to your
business and life and lastly number
three you're going to walk away with an
action plan that is specific detail what
timelines in achievable to living the
life that you really want section number
two getting rid of your limiting beliefs
when you discover who you truly are you
have your action plan and you're ready
to make your bold move
chances are you're going to get in your
own way you've had action plans before
but you have not follow-through you have
not taken consistent actions towards
your goals and we need to make sure that
you don't get in your own way the reason
why you haven't followed through in the
past is because of your habits your
environment the things that you say to
yourself and you have years of limiting
beliefs keeping you down you know you
have that voice that talks to you every
time you're ready to do something
courageous you know the voice that says
you're not good enough you don't have
the money you don't have the education
you have failed before what makes you
think that you're going to succeed this
so in this section we are going to put
an end to all of that once and for all
and we're going to do that by number one
identifying your limiting beliefs
through doing some reflexive exercises
number two we're going to figure out the
root cause of each of them and number
three is to replace all of those
negative thinking patterns with positive
actions you are also going to walk away
with exercises to help you in the moment
of self-doubt you know when that voice
comes back to talk to you you know
exactly what to do to combat it you will
also learn how to set up triggers in
your environment so that way you don't
have to force yourself to think about
being bold your environment is already
set up to force you to be bold every
single day section number three
contribution and impact once you have
the ability to change your own life you
have the responsibility to help people
make their lives better and create a
ripple effect where your entire
community yes it feels great to live a
life on your own terms and be able to
achieve your goals
but true fulfillment comes from giving
back however that looks like for you
whether if it's helping your friends and
family to your employees to leading a
world-changing mission either way you
have the responsibility in making a
contribution and we're gonna do that by
in number one figuring out the impact
that you want to have in this world
number two figuring out how you're going
to spread your message in your own
unique way each week we're going to meet
online for two hours I will introduce a
new topic we're gonna work through some
exercises together and you will leave
with a 24 hour mission which is a
tailored assignment for you to complete
within the next 24 hours to help you get
started you will also have an action
plan to complete within the week to help
carry you through to the following
session now I will also leave time in
each session for you to ask me questions
as well as give feedback regarding your
progress we will have assignments
progress reports and a Facebook group to
help you stay on the right
tract it's so amazing to me when we work
for other people how much of ourselves
are we willing to give to bosses that we
hate for the jobs that we hate but we're
not willing to give to ourselves the
school of life is for you this is about
you creating a life on your own terms
and you dot me as your coach I'm gonna
be cheering you on in your corner and
making sure that you follow through on
all your action plans and you know I am
NOT going to let you off the hook the
School of Life will take place every
Tuesday from 7:00 to 9:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
starting March 13th normally I charge a
hundred dollars us for a coaching
session with me however this nine-week
program is going to cost you two hundred
and forty seven dollars for 18 hours of
group coaching with me plus a Facebook
group and you will also have direct
access to me to answer any questions and
give you support I do want to let you
know this you are going to have my
personal support every step of the way
so that way you come out living the life
that you really want so for those of you
who are interested please email me at
lily and Evan Carmichael comm and I only
have nine spots so it's gonna be a very
intimate experience and to be honest
with you I'm not sure if this is going
to be my first and last time I ever
offer the School of Life so if you are
interested please please please please
email me as soon as you can I'm really
excited to go on this journey with you
and let's get started on building your
best life thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in class bye bye
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core values is that people passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details